Yes, yes that is a sock as a pop filter.
I forgot to pack it!
at least the audio is better than last video.
Why do you always have to complain, huh?
Why you always gotta find something wrong with everything?
*Le Why intro*
Welcome back to LWIAY YouTube's favorite show and yours, too, I hope
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm.
Let's review the memes from last week that you posted.
That's right!
You posted memes.
I get all the benefits. Let's do this.
You're welcome!
You mentioned you like Ed Sheeran, so I got you his new album
Saints Sainsbury's basics
15 cheesy singles
I was your Uber driver like three months ago leave me alone
*Felix's beautiful laugh*
That's that's I.I....I
This feels too conveniently set up, but I still enjoyed it.
These are really important
Important things all right memes needs to be authentic and clear okay.
Goodbye high school. I survived. I will never suffer again
never
job
relationship
No bonus meme ; ~ ;
Listen guys, I know this has been a problem for a while on the channel
There's been a severe lack of bonus memes on this channel
for I think that we're on a three or four week drought of
Bonus meme I am trying my best I am working on it
And I think tomorrow will be a bonus meme
I can't promise but I will do my best
Updates are ready to install not now my presentation is in 15 minutes
Updates will now be installed. Please no!
Your computer will now restart. Such a funny meme
What the f you even supposed to do with your hands while you're getting your [dick sucked]... Oh
*Felix's beautiful laugh once again*
*Claps*
Meme Review
it's the only thing you need to do it actually amplifies the experience trust me
I have tried. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
meme review makes everything better.
Where is the bonus meme?
There's no more time for bonus meme ; ~ ;
Then stop showing your chair every minute
Puts more chair memes stop it that meme instead
guys have I told you about my chai...
Why are we still here?
Just to suffer
Actually guys have I told you about my game A.S.S
It's coming out on Nintendo Gameboy
check out link in description for more info.
Let me see who you really are
Knew it
Just wait for the next one where they unmask him, and it'll be me again
And then another one and another one who you'll be like
*High pitched voice* I'm so creative and funny
Felix is so unfunny and unoriginal
Ton steps ahead at all times just wait for my master plan to be unwheeled you will all
feel super embarrassed picture of communism made out of pictures of YouTube
Fine you know what fine
That was funny clever good job, honey
Tell me what's wrong
what if Grande and Dolan is Brad one and Brad two
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmm
This is just a "Hmmmmm" meme isn't it?
If the earth is flat. How come Wi-Fi look like this and not like this
I'm glad Felix reviewed this meme on meme review because now it will finally die
Thank You Felix
Hey listen here you scumbag alright. It's not true. I make the memes more popular, which means
They die quicker
*Sad music*
Go fund me help me get Poodiepie's chair. Oh, wow alright. We're begging for money now
Huh? what's the next begging for content?
ridiculous, it's sort of
lowlife scumbags
Disgust me okay do your own work
Z U C K-bots activated
wireless charging. It's so cute. He has to sit on the booster
See, I just love how the Z U C C memes has just come back now. Thanks to this Congress video. I just
I want Z U C C to make one video a month
at least that would just genuinely make me happier and make my life so much better
Thank you Z U C C for all the memes. We appreciate you we love you
and we do subscribe to your reptilian Overlord god. Oh my god
Hypocrisy amirite?
This is what I'm talking about memes is not just to make you ha ha they're also made to make go
Hmmmmmmm
You know I'm saying does she bite nobody can hurt you in other ways
Your meme actually made it into le why but Brad one or Brad two edited it
That's really who you gotta get past there's a lot of times I pick
I pick a meme for the thumbnail like last video, and then it's not even in the edit
And I'm like what the Frick guys.
It's really who you want to impress here. It's not me. It's not reddit
It's Brad one, and two they're the gatekeepers
What's everyone listening to this morning?
Spotify
oh my god that is so savage
damn just coming over against a giant corporation that will most likely not respond or even see your message
That's insane the balls
The balls of this man woman.
I copied pood's old wall design turned out quite good
That is actually pretty good PewDiePie one
markiplier one
jacksepticeye one
total three
subscriber sixty one.
subscriber.
Twenty.
Subscribers eight.
Guys
Hey Brad one or two please edit out this meme
So they don't find out about the chair overlord
Conspiracy, thank you
I'm Yours. I love you Marzia.  I love you too
He's lying
He said the same thing to Brad what the Mark is
Zucker the Z U C C meme has just taken over the FBI meme now is that how?
We do it, and then I like it keep it up proud of you
am I Pregananant? Uploaded nine months ago
Hmmmmmmmmmmmm
Hmm it's pretty ascetic honestly well done
Just just look at the flowers see you guys should thank me for reviewing the memes
Okay, some some memes just needs to die
And you should all be thanking me and the reason isn't because I reviewed it
It's because I gave it a zero!
That's right a meme getting a zero review means, it's instant death.
Okay CNN drama alert fish news.
We news
Pew news that's right everybody the most trusted
legitimate news source on the Internet got the highest rating of approval from
Everyone literally everyone said it
Thank you guys for supporting independent news developer
Our whole team is working really hard here to get the the facts and nothing but the facts
God dammit
Is it really that bad?
I honestly didn't even know. God dammit
PewDiePie an alien newspaper with headline plays video games all day long and now earns millions per year
Wow is it 2013 yet to anyone
Bravo India you really keeping the curves man damn in China YouTube is blocked so someone makes
Sure to re-upload every PewDiePie video to YouKu
Not all heroes wears capes. Yeah, what a hero that steals all my revenue, huh?
What kind of lowlife degenerate scumbag will take someone else's content and monetize it?
Nytho
Huh? you tell me
leave your entries in.
IT HAS ADS!
I am sinking!
I'm so done. I'm legit. I'm done. This is this is legit from my video
This is the second time it happened last time. There was a vegana, There's straight-up a girl having the sex assess
The FBI meme just became so much better, thanks to the Z U C C just
Reskin or whatever to call it. I love it so cute
I have a feeling this week guys
I have a strong hunch, okay cannot confirm cannot confirm, but I have a good feeling this week might be the week
I can't fit bullying into the video well. He put it by or can I
It's really great, it's really great having people working for you really doing their best
to make you look the best at all times
Thank you guys really
Appreciate it the reason there is no bonus meme is because of Brad
That's right everybody, you really shouldn't be talking to me about this. This is completely out of my hands
Guys we've done it get well soon Johnny D
the whole squad famous with you. Oh, that's amazing honestly. Thanks to everyone that donated. That's really
really cool and impressive of you guys
It's gonna say your mom gay or something
God dammit
Seriously you don't need adblock. If you only watch your PewDiePie clearly.
just go to the Chinese version there
They have way better ads they're actually quite
Enjoyable the space we see inside Poodipie's closet
actual space instead PewDiePie's closet
It's got good room in here pretty good echo
I'm actually quite comfortable
and the top meme everybody he's being exposed. I didn't do anything come on
Please believe me. It's your daughter's birthday for God's sake
How did you know that?
The Z U C C meme has come back, and it's as glorious as ever.
Thank you guys for another episode of le why
great memes great times next one
We're gonna have it a little themed around Brad and and Brad two
so do keep an extra attention to those submit your memes in the
Description I mean in the reddit and remember to leave a thumbs up and share with everyone that you know ever
leave your entries in the subreddit bros